I
did circuit breakers a little while ago
watch
she does what
this one this one I came up with
where'd you find this stuff no no but I
do and when I do it I do it fast I want
to do it it's usually right
so the last one I have to worry about is
this
this is it
now we're pretty good
are you a hoarder I'm not a hoarder I'm
just a worker workaholic
and I like it though because I did a lot
of crap you know what my brothers they
always give me a lot to do but if it
wasn't
we're saving the the world they wouldn't
do it I believe that so I did the best I
can with what what they give me
I know how to work everything pretty
much
the best of my ability
and that's all I know because look
and these are different spots they
picked up this stuff so look at this one
because your dumpster this is a yeah
look at this it's a few circuit breaker
I don't know how it works but I just do
it
so how I did it was I just went like
this and I hooked on to which one to
hook onto Ruby what happened to your
cheek
ah
oh I had ah nothing
tell me what happened to your cheek
that's it
okay I don't know I just hurt myself I
think I scratched myself tonight I don't
think that's what happened yeah I did
tell me the truth I did I don't know if
I would not careful but I'll tell you
yeah later oh yeah you got cut
I gotta be flirt
somebody cut you with a knife now
now
but okay I just I got scratched oh look
what I got streets are rough
thank heaven what's that
Zeus gave a baby Hercules a special gift
hello
he's my favorite
besides that one
that one he I like him he's one of my
favorite in there
I can live with that I don't know who
that princess is but he's happier than
going to sleep he snuggled down to sleep
then Mouse and works it says what makes
for a good day for Ruby
um
you helping me
on days yeah
um so that makes every day a good day
yeah I do it does you helping me it does
you don't know how much that much
my day is um but finding [__] like this
all day
[Music]
what is that this is just a a little a
little stun gun and I brought to you a
couple of them so you get a couple of
these yeah I told you I had a couple
things for you oh you have gifts for you
yes that's all you got to do is put your
BBS in there and shoot it shoot their
asses right off that is a good one
because what
that's it it says it's not good that's
all oh that whistle so
so here's your dad here okay thank you
you're welcome
and I think that's
yeah so my day is really easy
I'll find something like this
then I put it together
and it's really bright inside watch
don't believe how bright it is in fact
look
at night I'll get you through the
neighborhood yeah so I put my little guy
on hitter
he's on head right now let's see if he
can light up
as I just mess around a lot with these
kind of things
they're fine
I've read a lot of things during the day
yeah
but I'm happy I'm a happy kid
[Applause]
that's it where do you eat infused
so what do you eat Ruby
25 250 milligrams of this no where do
you eat
um I eat all over but most of the time
at the the
um the free places yeah see that a lot
of those around yeah but they're good
yeah they they they feed me good
yeah and they're they got healthier
meals now out there believe it or not
they do
what we look at that bag
I got a Jaguar bag the other day
or Puma but that that looks like jaguar
to me I think that's Jaguar yeah I got
that one
that's a good one
and then if you want to learn something
Eureka Math
I don't know
I think you're hoarder
uh a lot of hoarder um
confused
yeah
about some deals and that I come across
no but I'm not a hoarder I actually
throw everything away or give it away
you hear me
I'm actually not a hoarder so hoarders
keep [__]
you think I don't you leave stuff behind
yeah I try I try to get rid of as much
as I can as soon as I'm done with
whatever I need
then I throw away like I got a gun a
real badass gun the other day it almost
shut off the wall of and and people
thought I was crazy
and I showed him what the hell gun was
what how are rifles supposed to sound
you looked at me like I was half nuts
but I said hey that's kind of [__] I get
every day you know what I'm saying I
could blow it off the wall or just or
just forget about it tomorrow or I could
do some hard for somebody why
I don't I try not to sometimes I do if
they're hurting me a lot because I got a
teaching their own lesson other than
that I'm good
I think it might just pop I hope so I've
been waiting for that part e day now sir
we're gonna get better in America what
are you hoping happens to Ruby in the
next three years
get out of my own place
um
take it about going back to school
really yeah that's great and when I'm
gonna go to school for is um architect
because I I love everything
with how it moves the system right now
and stuff it really surprised me I
believe that you're smart enough I just
don't believe you're sober enough yeah
but I'm gonna go to school for it all
and then I'm going to go to school I
don't wanna I wanna I don't want to go
to like oh book work no we're going to
go straight to the Hands-On Hands-On you
teach me
as we go you know let's make a house and
[__] let's make something you want to
build something I don't want to go
through the school school part of it I
want to go to the Dynamics of the the
frame you just want to start building
yeah yeah right I want to go to the
frame I want to know how frame is
supposed to be how
how to frame you have to have a subordin
or if a new device could come out
if they'll accept that for a deal you
know so I got a lot of things in my mind
to do
and that deal thing is going to be good
because I'm going to go to school and
I'm going to really try to sell myself
to them
but I'm gonna I gotta figure it out a
little bit more like yours
this makes me you are my favorite you
hear me out here on the streets you and
a couple other guys I think I got like
six that I wrote like tough with right
I'm sure what they say
I told you the other day where I felt
about you and I read that then when I
see my sister's soul
they oh that broke my heart I said I
can't have anything better than that you
hear me so on good days like just people
that do like things for me like that
like you don't even know
like my daughter looks this is what my
daughter did for me I swear to God watch
she makes these she makes these for the
[__] for the the tweet tweet girls so
I put it on but it was her face every
day she was wearing them too in her
little [__] face it was like half
never but you can tell that was under
her teeth and [__] but it was her and I
said oh my God you see what you said she
said the heart what the star ones so I
thought that was really interesting
about how I'm gonna [__] piece my
girl or my knot no I think
you know they should talk a lot of [__]
but they don't know [__] about me and I
like it that way sometimes yeah
but it's good [__] brother you're so
interesting yes and you are too because
I love I love everything that you do
like
for the Earth
um these lotions and everything that you
have done like for the the beauty of a
skin I think you're awesome I think
you're awesome thank you and I just want
the world to know that you know
sometimes you can be jealous of people
and and it's not even worth it because
that person would probably help you
no matter even if
why hurt somebody over what they have
you should be grateful for what you got
that day and know that if you just baby
sometimes ask for help you don't have to
hurt on somebody or being on somebody or
threaten somebody because it's not
working no more
all my angels and all my Devils have
came out and proved it
and I've seen it for myself so I'm
grateful and you should be trying to be
grateful too out there people watching
this because um there's a lot
uh there's a lot of pain out here in
these streets yes there is you don't
know how really sick people can get and
they're really sick but what I know is
I got Angels in the Outfield
hitting home runs all the time and I'm
dodging them catching them and
whatever it takes but
I don't know if
it's the sun that's what I've came up
with
she's my maker right now
not like that but she said that
she owns everything like us going
through this stuff that I'm going
through right now and it's the end of it
right now I'm not sitting you it's the
end of it but
she's the one that does the
mechanism and how the I heard it already
it's the Sun that gives us
what our body can take
so she bounces down I talk to her and
she goes like this someday she's so
bright and twiddling in the middle next
time look at the sun look the Sun every
day for me for about a month okay
and sometimes she'll bring down like
this
like she's gonna come and hit something
for me you know and when she does [__]
like that it's awesome
God told her I don't know if it's a boy
or girl because I don't and I don't know
if the moon's a boy or girl but I see
the sun and the moon come out the same
day did he see that the other day
yeah yeah it came out well the Sun and
the Moon in the morning time and look it
happens it's about
seven or eight days ago nine days ago go
back and see when the sun and the moon
was out the same day Ruby I'm sure I've
asked you this before where do you sleep
um everywhere do you sleep sometimes
yeah but when I sleep I usually sleep
two days how many days do you go without
sleep about 10
but then I then I sleep like for two
days right yeah but that's about my
sleep pattern
but I have I'm good
you are good yeah I'm going through it
but we're gonna be okay you're a
beautiful person
you are too but I don't feel it right
now because it's so like
I would love to know what you're like
what you were like before you got into
drugs
the same person yeah but your your your
mind is so sharp and interesting and
your energy is so great I bet you were
fascinating before you got into trouble
with drugs
yeah I'm not in trouble with drugs I
didn't stop at any time people don't
know that about me though
see I just do this as a facade out here
right now because they want to act like
they're gonna steal some [__] for me
well for some reason Houdini gots that
[__] coming right back in my bag as soon
as they steal it it goes right back in
there and you have kids
I have five kids I have five kids and I
believe ten monkeys
I don't doubt that
ten monkeys is what I think real like
the ones that I don't know for a fact
but I think it's four four and two
that's how it went so however they did
it they did it perfect because what are
your kids names
um Nina Jasmine
Reginald
shame
and Jewel so I have jewelry Raven
Evans have shame
Shane Dean Evans I have Reginald Robert
Evans III have nine of Fades until I
have um Jasmine Elizabeth Crossway what
are your monkeys names huh what are your
monkeys names
um the only one I've seen I called him
Zeus I liked him
or I named him um what was his other
name when's the last time you saw your
kids
it's been a while but that's okay
because whenever I walked out of that
courtroom and I told that judge I
couldn't do nothing because I have a
disease and I can't help myself right
now and I can't come and hurt them
so I'm not going to visit with them I
told him that whenever it's time for me
to come back if there ever is I'll never
want to take them away from their
parents that they have now I don't who
are they being raised by I don't know
it doesn't matter
but I know it's somebody somebody's real
special
and um I never will take them away I
just want to see them what was it first
and I don't ever want to it's like maybe
a weekend room vacation who knows we
could do that a couple times or
something like like that sort you know
but I promise the parents I'd never take
them away what was the beginning of your
problem a mental problem or a drug
problem no it was nothing like that it's
just I got sick and then I couldn't I
couldn't help him I couldn't do it and
I'm I just couldn't do it at the time I
don't know what happened but I think he
got taken away I don't remember
um I think it was because yeah me and my
mom my stepdad of me we got a fight and
I threw a pumpkin at the fence and the
cop comes and said that he just said I
threw a pumpkin at him well they took me
to Jail the next day my mom died the
next day I got out or something like
that and my mom I really thought I see
my mom years later four years later
three years later in the U-Haul truck
so I know my mom's not dead
but I'm not for sure
because my aunt has her ashes
I don't really know
I because my mother always told me she's
going to be one of those people no
matter what she's probably an angel out
there doing it I don't know if she has
passed away because she said she's gonna
go to every island out there and she
gonna is she gonna go and find her
pearls or whatever she's gonna be a
diamond Hunter she's gonna get it all
that was her she was always into that
one movie um
I don't know if you read this book but
it was a
it was from um
it was called what was it called
jewels of the Nile
that the book you got to get it and read
it Jewel of the Nile I don't know what
that book is amazing and that other one
where the white boy and the Mexican girl
are out there fishing and they're out
there and they're fighting diamonds
and she always said she was a gypsy
right and my mom always said that she
she loves Pirates of the Caribbean
because she said she she knows that she
would roll with those boats with the
gypsies
back to the day and I said what are you
talking about well she did she knew she
didn't know a lot of people like like
there was this guy Giles that used to
pick me up when I was a little kid and
he'd come in the limo and it was her
personal service
wherever she needed to go because she
worked for Fitzgerald restaurant and
that was across the street from Angel
Stadium so she would meet people from a
major Stadium or wherever stadium and
she would go out like to dinners and
stuff they'd invite her if they weren't
coming like to her dinner for
for the night like they would invite her
somewhere else my mom yeah she was
always up high paid in person and we
always were at like
Las Vegas for the weekend or the
Colorado River or some [__] we were
always doing something no matter what we
were gone for the weekend good memories
of you Charlotte huh you have good
memories of your childhood oh yeah my
parents they were good I had I had one
stepdad it was a armored truck so I
could he had Rob on my trucks that's
what he'd do he'd go up he'd hit him
get me off your body like big time back
in the days she did 25 years for that
[__] already but he got out but he used
to hit those [__] from Florida
all the way to California
and I could always remember he'd be one
daughter my mom when he comes but he had
money and he'd hit these trucks and he'd
go bury the money
so it was real [__] but he had he had he
had his buddy and one day one year the
[__] fence came in shut my grandma's
house down told my grandma where's the
money at my stepdad said my little
brother he had to ask my brother he said
my dad went up in the attic so go to the
attic and they felt it but they were
going to tear all the Wells on my
grandma's house
they didn't find that money
that's the only [__] Heist he got
caught on
yeah but that's good [__] yeah and also
all my step daddy's they were crazy
mother said that it would stop my mom
out in front of UPS where she'd work and
here's a truck driver from Texas she
buried him my mom was married like five
or no I think like six seven times she
married my Mexican dad two times
she married
Andy Andy I think one time they got
divorced because Dan and her who else
changed me yeah um to him
Roger Roger and another Roger she
married to Roger Grisham and Roger so
that's
that's yeah six seven yeah that's that's
right
so yeah she married and she divorced
them and yeah getting another one and
but we always have a good life you know
she is always doing something always
good what was your favorite memory as a
kid
I'll be at my grandma's house
I was at my grandma's house always had
the best the best years there
like um she'd always make me like
cakes pound cakes with frosting and
strawberries everything and everything
was always perfect like every party was
always perfect you know as is always
wonderful my life was always good with
my grandma and my mom
yeah how old are you uh 4 43. but they
tell me I'm 40 44.
I think I'm 42. well you were you born
so I'm 42 I'm 40 to 42.
April so you're 44. 44. okay okay that's
what they say they say 43 or 40 I don't
know they didn't tell me 44 now almost
went out but okay um that that's what I
am
I don't know I lost track
yeah
yep yep and I'm sorry but
I appreciate you
and I mean that telling you that
because you I think you're a wonderful
guy to go out here and
listen to all these stories that all
these people have
and
and everything like I'm so blessed to
have brothers the way I have brothers
right now
that have been there for me because if
you guys weren't on it for a lot of
people we would be dead you know that
really you get yourself in trouble
sometimes yeah but I don't know how the
[__] board looks lots of stuff
in the dinner whatever the hell's down
in there because I know why I don't know
but it's all good whatever it is we're
gonna be okay that volcano did you hear
about that volcano erupted just recently
oh it's beautiful it was the prettiest
red the sky was red and the the lava was
so red and
on this side it's like purple purple
where the black was I never seen it in
my life like that but it was like a real
light purple and did it go like into
black lava how it's cooling down oh it's
the neatest thing I've seen
yeah I see that on TV wait was your dad
in your life
my okay my Bible just called Dad no he
wasn't really no my grandparents were
but not him
yeah he was he was um he wasn't gone all
the time whatever but my grandparents
they me I had a good life with them
yeah and then my stepdad
I'll be my real dad he'd come around
sometimes did your grandparents raise
you mostly uh my grandparents you know
my mom your mom did my mom my mom and my
stepdad my stepdad's house 15 then my
mom married Roger and then my mom stay
with Roger how far did you go to school
all went all the way but I graduated uh
six months early before graduation day
and you got married when
I got married
I think I was 28. 28 no
29.
I think that's like 34 around there your
husband's a good guy
he was for a while until no and then I
couldn't be with somebody like that so I
just left
yeah because um I don't believe in a
marriage you should cheat on your spouse
and that's what he was doing
so I had to leave other than that um
yeah I left
life is hard isn't it
it was at first but then I got over it
because then I seen how how ruthless
being could be some of them but I know
there's a lot of good men out there
still I know there's a lot of good men
that stick with the relationships and
everything so I know one day
my prince has come for me if you don't
that's okay and I fell in love with this
black dude and and it was my sister that
he was married to and he said that she
left and they came and they seen me
like on the corner right here it was
just right here
and I fell I said maybe I'm gonna be
with him and then they got back together
and it was the best thing like it made
me cry made me cry so much because I
fell in love with him
a different way but not like that
and then when I see to her I said
there's no way
absolutely no way
I'd ever go
and be with him ever again since I knew
not again we never were together but
thinking on that level like he said
after you get out of jail or whatever
you come back and stay with me
but then they had gotten back to get him
so I said oh man
uh it was good it all ended up the way
it was supposed because he got back
together I think and she's a beautiful
woman and he's a beautiful man you know
so I was so happy that they were
together
when I found out but yeah that's true
but yeah I fell in love with that dude
and I was thinking and then damn you
know I don't know but but I had to be
happy because that's the best thing I
see you can get your heart broken and
Skid Row yeah because Noah wasn't skid
row it was in San Bernardino yeah it was
it was been a while yeah but
I fall in love and Out of Love
but yeah I got that
not right now and me because my problem
that I had but I'm gonna get there
it's just a little bit of time
you're right Ruby is nice seeing you
again you too you're talking to you
again yes I see you every day
so this is it
all right Ruby thank you very much yes
sir
frequency